watch how then throughout the oscars it
continued their intersectional
road to hell continued here are uh
comedians amy schumer and wanda sykes
along with actress regina hall i don't
have to put i think she's an actress i
don't have to put quotes around it but i
will put quotes around amy schumer uh
comedian and wanda sykes comedian
making fun of florida over the don't say
gay bill we're gonna have a great night
tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
the only one who i half respect there is
john travolta who didn't laugh at the
joke and isn't he gay or he's half gay
or something i'm not outing john
travolta i don't know does or he goes
and gets massages from people i don't
know what he's doing but he just he's
like uh you [ __ ] people but they're
oh my god they said the thing and it's
not based in reality and
meanwhile they're all sitting in that
room by the way uh and nobody's wearing
a mask again i saw pictures on the red
carpet and stuff the staffs are still
wearing masks the photographers the
people that serve them still wearing
masks
but let's just put that aside let's also
put aside the fact that there is no such
thing as a don't say gay bill there is a
bill that is related to transparency in
school so why don't we just unpack that
because while these people live in their
faux reality while they make a [ __ ] ton
of money to judge you and then you pay
to have them judge you with their crappy
movies there are a couple people out
there who are fighting this endless
[ __ ] there happens to be this guy
what's his name over here in florida
he's doing a pretty good job and then
you had this governor's race in virginia
where you had the losing candidates say
parents that he said parents should not
be involved in what is taught in the
school system and so
there is a debate in this country
about what role parents have in the
education of their kids and i think in
florida with our parents bill of rights
with the bill we're going to sign here
today which bill other bills we're going
to sign later uh we believe
parents not only have a role they have a
fundamental role to be involved in the
education of their kids all right so you
get it you get how hollywood works this
is what they do this is a bunch of lefty
rich elitists who are trying to push all
of their views which actually have
nothing to do with reality because as
you know the word gay is not in the bill
okay and this has this is about
kindergartners through third graders
not talking about gender identity and
sexuality with state employees and then
allowing the state employees to hide
that from the parents but these people
just sit there and they applaud them oh
my god we love gays so much it's
actually offensive to actual gays that
just want to function in the world
morons uh well desantis is continuing to
go on so he's he's not uh given up on
that he's pushing back on that he's also
going to ban porn in schools i did not
know that porn was in schools
i'm old school born in 76 i was in grade
school in the early 80s we didn't have
um we didn't have porn in school i'm
trying to remember we watched i remember
there was a week where in social studies
we watched a show called the voyage of
the mimi did you guys see that it's like
about a bunch of people they go whale
hunting i think in alaska it's pretty
good one of the people gets hypothermia
it's a whole situation that's what we
watched when i was a kid apparently
there's porn in schools album not here
in florida unfortunately we've seen some
uh some books in some of these libraries
i mean you're talking about kids in
middle school some of the stuff that has
ended up there
incredibly
incredibly disturbing stuff
you have some groups that want to take
away
classic books like to kill a mockingbird
but they want things like gender queer a
memoir which is a cartoon style book
with graphic images of children
performing sexual acts that is wrong
that has no place in the schools they
want to eliminate of mice and men
but lawn boy a book containing explicit
passages of pedophilia is somehow
accepted as being okay parents want
education for their kids they're not
interested in indoctrination
through the school system and that's
where
[Applause]
education not indoctrination hollywood
wants to indoctrinate and they do it
through the system it just is it's a
it's sort of a depressing reality
because there's a lot of good stuff that
used to come out of hollywood we all
have movies we love and and shows we
love whether it's game of thrones or
sopranos or total recall or interstellar
or whatever the hell you used to love
star wars is a great example of it
because star wars when george lucas was
originally creating it was creating this
anti-establishment thing he fought the
studios that's actually the backstory of
star wars and then he was as an
individual created this incredible story
that captured the imagination of
generations of people generations of
people and then ultimately he sold the
company and i don't begrudge him for
selling the company and he was you know
the fans had sort of turned him against
him after the prequels which is very
unfortunate because the prequels are
actually pretty good um but he sold it
to the giant corporation that exists on
earth disney and then disney completely
destroyed star wars and then they push
all of this nonsense messaging so what
is it that hollywood is protesting when
amy schumer is up there dancing gay gay
gay it's like amy schumer what are you
really saying is it very very important
to you that a first grader is taught
that just because they have a penis it
doesn't mean they're a boy and that the
teacher should hide that from the parent
is that really what you what you're
saying